der fil Länder der raumsonder Rosetta
hat seinen Landeplatz gefunden die USA
schicken 3000 Soldaten in den Kampf
gegen Ebola und warum Schockbilder auf
zigarettenverpackung nur wenig bewirken
das sind drei der Themen jetzt in den
klickum Top 5 News aus dem klickum.de
Blog Obama gegen Ebola US-Präsident
Barack Obama möchte effektiver gegen die
Ebola Epidemie in Westafrika Vorgehen
aus diesem Grund plant die amerikanische
Regierung 3000 Soldaten zu entsenden die
die medizinischen Hilfskräfte
unterstützen zudem gab die US-Regierung
bekannt die globale
Gesundheitsinfrastruktur zu verstärken
und die Epidemie direkt in Westafrika
anzugehen Obama sieht weitreichende
Konsequenzen der solche durch die
fortschreitende Verbreitung des Erregers
könnten weltweit Wirtschaftssysteme
zusammenbrechen und panikwellen
losgetreten werden die diese
sicherheitspolitischen und ökonomischen
Konsequenzen gilt es zu vermeiden in den
kommenden sechs Monaten sollen
wöchentlich bis zu 500 örtliche Pflege
ekräfte im Umgang mit Ebola geschult
werden zudem sollen Medikamente und
Desinfektionsmittel an hundertausende
Haushalte verteilt werden um die globale
Verbreitung zu stoppen benötigt die Welt
Gesundheitsorganisation allerdings rund
eine Milliarde
Dollar der fländer landet auf dem
Kometenkopf der fländer der Raumsonde
Rosetta hat einen geeigneten Landeplatz
gefunden unter fünf möglichen
Landesstellen für das Weltraumlabor
haben sich die Verantwortlichen
Wissenschaftler entschieden bei dem
Landeplatz der Mission Hand es sich um
eine abwechslungsreiche aber nicht so
sehr zerklüftete Landschaft mit einer
guten Beleuchtung durch die Sonne und
kaum steilen Hängen so die deutschen
Forscher des deutschen Zentrums für Luft
und Raumfahrt kurz DLR die Landung des
fil länders wird quasi auf dem Kopf des
Kometen 67p turumov gerassimenko
standfinden wie wir auf aktuellen
nafnahmen sehen ist der Komet turimov
gerassimenko eine schöne und zugleich
sehr extreme Welt er ist
wissenschaftlich spannend hat aber eine
Form die für die Landung eine große
Herausforderung darstellt mein DLR
Wissenschaftler Dr Stefan ulermeck
Projektleiter für den
filländer keine Schockbilder mehr auf
zigarettenverpackung Schockbilder und
warnende Botschaften haben nicht auf
alle Raucher einen Effekt auf die
Entwöhnung von Zigaretten das fanden
Forscher am Georgetown Lombardi
comprehensive cancer Center in den USA
in einer Studie mit 740 Probanden heraus
dabei kam heraus dass die Wirkung der
Botschaft abhängig von der Sucht des
Rauchers ist traut sich ein Raucher die
Entwöhnung von der Zigarette zu helfen
positive Bilder oder Botschaften anders
hingegen bei Rauchern die sich nur
schwer von der Zigarette trennen wollen
in solchen Fällen sein Schockbilder und
todeswarnung sinnvoller unsere Studie
zeigt dass man mehr Raucher zum Aufhören
bringen kann wenn man sowohl positive
als auch negative Botschaften einsetzt
meint Darren may Leiter der Studie das
Problem sei dass die meisten Botschaften
auf Zigarettenpackung auf die Gefahren
von Tabakkonsum hinweisen damit könne
man aber nicht alle Raucher
überzeugen curiosity erreicht sein Ziel
der Mars Rover curiosity hat sein Ziel
am Fuß des Berges Mount Sharp erreicht
dort soll der forschungsroboter die
Umgebung erkunden mit leichter
Verspätung hat die NASA ihren Rover auf
dem roten Planeten zu seinem
Bestimmungsort geleitet um den 5,5 km
hohen Berg zu erreichen musste der Mars
Rover zunächst eine Entfernung von 8 km
zurücklegen das ist eine Menge der fährt
nämlich ziemlich langsam wie lange er
dafür brauch uchen würde war für die
Wissenschaftler nicht klar nach
Problemen mit den Rädern des
forschungsroboters wurde letztendlich
sogar die geplante Route geändert damit
der Rover über ebenes Gebiet fahren
konnte es war ein langer aber
historischer Weg zu diesem Marsberg
sagte nasawissenschaftler John
grotzinger jetzt soll curiosity den Berg
erklimmen dort soll er die
unterschiedlichen Gesteinsschichten
untersuchen zwei Sonnenstürme Rasen auf
die Erde zu zwei magnetisch geladene
Sonnenstürme sind um den 12 September
auf die Erde zugerast dieses Ereignis
erregte Besorgnis um die
Funktionstüchtigkeit von
radiokommunikation GPS-Sendern und das
Stromnetzes ein einzelner Sonnensturm
stellt meistens keine Gefahr da durch
den ungewöhnlichen Doppelschlag der
Sonnenstürme sowie den direkten Kurs auf
der Erde wurden die Sorgen um die
Auswirkung größer das Besondere in
diesem Fall ist dass wir es mit zwei
direkt aufeinander folgenden Stürmen zu
tun haben und dass sich die koronalen
Massenauswürfe möglicherweise auf ihrem
Weg zur Erde gegenseit
beeinflussen entweder noch im Orbit oder
auf der Erde selbst wir wissen es nicht
meinte Thomas Berger Direktor des
National Oceanic and atmospheric
Administration space weather prediction
Center die beiden Stürme hatten dann
aber doch Gott sei Dank keine
Auswirkungen auf die Erde was hätte
passieren können das erkläre ich in
diesem Video hier klicken die Folgen
können nämlich verheerend sein täglich
News gibt es im Blog oder in der App
dafür hier klicken also oben fürs Video
unten für den Blog alle Links natürlich
wie immer in der Videobeschreibung und
was meint ihr wie kann die Ebola
Epidemie eingedämmt werden wie wird es
damit weitergehen diskutiert es wie
immer mit mir in den Kommentaren
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran